Heads up, folks, major Avengers: Infinity
War spoilers coming your way.
"I'll listen to you...
til this is empty."
The supersized Marvel blockbuster dished out
very little mercy in its heartbreaking ending
that saw big-name heroes bite the dust, literally.
While some characters' fates were seemingly
sealed, others were left up for interpretation,
like Valkyrie and the Asgardians, who didn't
appear in the film.
Now, Infinity War co-director Joe Russo has
revealed what happened to Tessa Thompson's
hard-drinking Valkyrie and the rest of the
Asgardian refugees.
That is, unless you choose to take Thompson's
word that she was in fact in the film as,
well, a baby goat.
For a refresher, Infinity War picks up where
Thor: Ragnarok left off, with the tense scene
aboard the Grandmaster's refugee vessel that
carried Thor, Loki, Hulk, Heimdall, Valkyrie,
and the rest of the rescued citizens of Asgard.
Thanos and his Black Order battered Thor in
an attempt to extract the Space Stone from
the Tesseract, then stabbed Heimdall through
the chest, intercepted Hulk, and offed Loki.
Infinity War then carried on directly after
Loki took his last breath, not bothering to
address Valkyrie and the remaining Asgardians.
During a Q&A at his old high school in Iowa
City, Joe Russo confirmed that Valkyrie survived
Thanos' surprise attack.
A student who attended Russo's presentation
took to Reddit to relay the information.
The user wrote: "He did confirm that Valkyrie
lived."
Russo didn't reveal exactly how the heroine
made it out alive, but given that he mentioned
a portion of the Asgardians on the ship had
fled using "escape pods," it's safe to assume
that Valkyrie may have done the same.
Though ducking away from a major battle doesn't
quite seem like something Valkyrie would do,
perhaps she was tasked with ensuring the last
Asgardians evacuated safely.
Sadly, those wondering what happened to Korg,
the adorable Kronan warrior voiced by Thor:
Ragnarok director Taika Waititi, won't be
as pleased with Russo's remarks.
"I'm made of rocks, as you can see, but don't
let that intimidate you.
You don't need to be afraid unless you're
made of scissors.
Heh heh.
Just a little rock-paper-scissors joke for
ya."
The same Reddit user indicated that they asked
Russo whether Korg survived the ambush, but
the filmmaker answered that he wasn't, quote,
"willing to say what his fate was," at least
not at this time.
So there you have it, Marvel fans: A bunch
of our precious heroes may be gone for good,
but Valkyrie is definitely still alive.
Silver linings, right?
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!